this is the matthews family
like most with children months off
school is taking its toll
they're at that um stage you know the
the types of stuff they're learning the
basics of reading and writing and it is
quite
um quite important that you get that
right so i am worried that
i mean richie doesn't enjoy writing and
so we we found that a bit of a struggle
to to try and get him to do that at home
and i think it's a bit different because
the teachers have a bit more clout than
those parents are you able to tell me
what it's like being at home all the
time
god it's good is it good
except from all the skill work
we now have the results of the biggest
ever study into lockdown learning
data from nearly one and a half million
children shows
all primary year groups have been
adversely affected
particularly the youngest before the
pandemic
79 of year ones met average targets in
writing
after the first lockdown that fell to 54
reading attainment went from 82 to 60
percent
but the biggest drop was in maths from
83 percent
to 59 after lockdown
and these results don't take into
account the most recent
closures not a lockdown skeptic i voted
for the government measures but i am a
school down skeptic especially when
the science now suggests that schools
don't
have a big risk let's get the schools
open let's have no backsliding in terms
of the 8th
of march catch-up classes and shortened
holidays are being discussed but this
head teacher says
they need to be handled with caution i
think teachers are
well equipped with how they can get them
back up to scratch with their reading
writing and maths
i do worry about the language being used
around it
because what we're saying to these
children is you're behind and
everybody's in the same position and for
this family the main issue isn't with
missing school
it's with missing friends especially for
their youngest
five-year-old luke he had a little
friend dropping a letter off through the
letterbox with a picture this week which
meant a lot to him and
it's just the people that use the plate
they don't get the play time so much
with
with the peers so i think that's the
thing that they miss the most and
i think they'll appreciate the most when
they go back teachers told us the vast
majority of children will bounce back
once in school but it's kids from more
disadvantaged backgrounds who have
fallen behind most
and will be slowest to catch up
catherine of autopsy sky news in
cheshire